this data science spotlight video is
comprised of 15
interview subjects who assisted with or
took part in the data science at nlm
training course
the visuals include the training course
classroom activity
six tables set in three rows there was a
laptop for each participant
one instructor stood at the front of the
class next to a projector screen
some interviewees appear more than once
here they are in order of appearance
linda collins lister hill national
center for biomedical communications
lhc victor sid also with lhc
nho with library operations samir antani
with lhc
eric sayers with the national center for
biotechnology information
cbi marie gallagher with lhc
lucas wagner with ncbi boshon goo
with ncbi alyssa dillman with ncbi
philip bond with library operations
linda collins once again
with lhc melanie houston with library
operations
nho once again with library operations
victor sid once again with lhc
olivier bodenrider with lhc
charlie liu within cbi kate majewski
with the office of engagement and
training
victor sid once again with lhc pricky
coker with library operations
linda collins once again with lhc and
eric sayers once again with ncbi
finally ending with samir and tani once
again with lhc
title text data science at nlm logo
instructor at the front of the class
students working on laptops and peter
cooper assisting with the class
generally say that linear regression
determines the under effect
unless the data itself is linear
how do you know that it undereffects any
ideas after taking this course about
data science i'm realizing that i do it
and i didn't know that before
i thought because i wasn't a scientist
it didn't apply to me
but after taking the course i realized
that it does apply to me and i use it
every day
and i want to learn how to do it better
and more efficiently student victor sid
listens to the instructor the data
science program allows me to
learn new techniques refresh things that
i know but
i need to practice and very importantly
has allowed me to
meet new people other people doing
similar work
student nho works on her laptop i've
learned
more statistics and python programming
and how a lot of different fields really
come together
to actually perform data science
the data science training program
actually offered an opportunity
not only to to test your skills
but also to see what's out there what
are different ways of doing something
perhaps
a better way of solving problems that
you've been
tackling student laptops display graphs
and charts and an
instructor assists a student i think
it's been
a great experience for a number of
people to have had a program like this
because
one of the things i think that's helped
do is kind of define data science for
people and make it more accessible
some of the most important things that
i've learned so far in the
data science class would be how to slice
and dice the
data in different ways i've also learned
that
not all the variables matter in your
data so how to pick
which variables matter i would say those
are the big things that i've learned so
far
student lucas wagner asks the instructor
a question
the emphasis on modeling and
machine learning is is my main interest
and uh those
you know those have been topics that the
class is covering and that's very
interesting
as well as an overview of tools that i
had some familiarity with but the
curriculum is
you know a very useful way of looking at
parts of them that i probably wouldn't
have looked at myself
i'm interested in this area and you know
the data science
they developed very fast these days
always wondering how we can use this new
technology
our daily activities
data science in general not just nlm or
nih
or or you know broader the whole
community is kind of figuring out right
now
where data science fits in in different
subject matter expertise and in the
communities and and
where they can apply that knowledge
philip bond sits in his cubicle working
at his computer i support data science
at nlm by
compiling reports and using
analytical tools that that's available
to me to
provide to all the senior staff at hand
so that they can plan accordingly
linda collins sits in her cubicle
working at her computer
i support data science mostly when i'm
doing payroll and itas
and when i'm helping people to prepare
to retire i have to go back three years
and go through
all their pay stubs and count up leave
without pay
how much leave they took how much sick
leave they took all of that has to
balance out
i am piloting a type of position i guess
a data science liaison
position in the index section sort of
keeping an eye on the data science
training program and helping people in
the section get the most they can get
out of that i've
been helping people select courses
or taking the courses answering
questions about python
nho sits in her office working at her
computer
i think i support data science by
working on terminologies
terminologies can help connect a lot of
different types of data
and in that sense create data exchange
today i'm using machine learning
algorithms to
address problems related to recognizing
automatically
information out of the internet
basically and help
the indexing of documents at the listed
health center we've been doing data
science
long before data science school graphics
of brain scans data and equations
scrolling upwards typically listel
researchers
process large data sets of biomedical
text images and structured data
they do so using inferential statistics
machine learning and now
deep learning techniques so let's say
researchers provide a great example
of data science in action graphics of
microscopic images and corresponding
data
in ncbi we own lots of data some raw
data some
curated data and i'm always
wondering if we can
extract some knowledge and
that way we can make the end user
save them time to
look through all the data try to come up
with a hypothesis
come up with the idea student kate
majewski
sitting at the back of the class
listening to the instructor
the advice i would give to my colleagues
who want to be
involved in data science would be to
talk to our
data science experts here at nlm the
folks who have been doing the science
for many years now
talk to the folks who are taking the
course right now to learn about
specifically what tools might meet the
needs that they have
in work because i think when you say
data science it's just it's a large
collection of different tools
and sometimes it can be a daunting thing
to try to figure out which tool is best
for a specific job
various classroom shots laptops and
students getting help from instructors
talk to people devote some time during
the week
to a network to talk to other colleagues
in the library
many people doing data science like me
enjoy telling others about what the work
we do
student pretty coker working in a data
science application
and start small and don't feel like you
have to like
you know get it all at once because it's
going to be a process
you know just like anything worth
learning it's a process
i just feel like the more you know about
data science and the more you use it
it'll help you incorporate it into your
daily work to make it easier and faster
keep an open mind to it i mean like it's
it's not something that's really scary
it's just an
opportunity to learn and an opportunity
to to find some skills that
really could help your your job and help
you do your job better
graphic of spinning columns of data we
have moved from
a world where we were merely storing
information
to a world where we can help others
understand that information
through this data science principles
graphic of a multi-colored stream of
data
title text data science at nlm logo